the drive to the world's most secure
prison is beautiful federal government's
only supermax prison known as ATX is 90
miles south of Denver standing outside
the building ATX looks like a newish
suburban middle school the lobby is
clean and bright
there's big windows and clear views of
the mountains and a plate front desk
attendant with a kiosk selling travel
mugs on the wall is a large plaque that
reads the best prize that Life offers is
the chance to work hard at work worth
doing just passed it as a huge frame
photo of Alcatraz and down the stairs at
the end of a long hallway are 400 men
decaying in isolation cells I work on
cases involving the constitutional
rights of prisoners now people have
differing views about prisoners rights
but there's something more people can
agree on torture the US government says
it doesn't use torture and we condemn
other countries like Iran and North
Korea for their use of torture but some
people think the so-called worst of the
worst deserve it
terrorists mass murderers the really bad
people now I personally believe that no
one deserves to be tortured by the US
government
but that's me
no matter where you fall there's a few
things I need you to understand before I
continue first we do torture people here
in America tens of thousands of them
every day
it's called solitary confinement it's
done in our names using our tax dollars
behind closed doors and as a result were
undermining the core values of our
justice system built with
state-of-the-art technology EDX has
nearly perfected solitary confinement
each man spends 23 hours a day alone in
a Cell the size of a small bathroom
virtually every aspect of his life
occurs in that cell but aside from
sleeping and eating which he does within
arm's reach of his toilet there aren't
many aspects of life correctional
officers push food trays through slots
and the doors and take the men to
solitary exercise cages that are
referred to by prisoners and staff alike
without irony as dog runs other than
that these men are locked in cement
closets all day every day two steps
forward two steps back
that's it they can't see the nearby
mountains or any trees nothing living
not so much as a blade of grass is how
one man in a TX described it some people
report that after years of not looking
at anything further than ten feet away
their eyesight has deteriorated so much
that they can't focus on faraway objects
anymore the isolation is so deep and
profound that one of our clients would
lie on the floor of his cell for hours
just hoping to catch a glimpse of
someone's feet as they walked past the
door of his cell another befriended a
wasp that flew into his cell feeding it
and talking to it like a friend some try
to communicate with fellow prisoners by
yelling through the shower drains still
though many of these men lost their
voices after talking with us for just an
hour their vocal cords were out of
practice speaking for that long we know
the impact of long-term isolation is
devastating this borders on common sense
it's why harsh prison systems and
torture regimes routinely use solitary
as a for
severe punishment and why none of us
would tolerate having a loved one like a
parent or a child locked alone in a
small bathroom for days let alone years
or decades in the course of representing
that first client at ADX we learned
about another man
Tommy silverstein who the Federal Bureau
of Prisons put in solitary confinement
under a no human contact order in 1983
after he killed a corrections officer
tommy was 31 years old now he's 66 he's
been in solitary confinement for 35
years struggling to find the words to
capture his experience of ADX
Tommy who has become an accomplished
artist drew it instead unless we start
to change how we treat prisoners in this
country
he'll probably be there for the rest of
his life
both John McCain and Nelson Mandela said
that of all the horrors they suffered in
prison solitary confinement was the
worst
that's because solitary puts people at
risk of losing their grasp on who they
are of how and whether they're connected
to a larger world as psychologists dr.
Craig Haney explains that's because
human identity is socially created we
understand ourselves through our
relationships with other people
solitary confinement can make you change
what you think about yourself it can
make you doubt whether you even have a
self some people in solitary aren't even
sure they exist
so they'll mouth off to a corrections
officer and end up getting shackled or
beaten but at least then they know they
exist over time some of the men and ADX
freaked out in obvious ways like banging
their heads on the walls of their cells
or smearing their cells with feces or
attempting suicide
some of them successfully many people
cut themselves just to feel the pain
that keeps them tethered to the real
world
others adjust showing no outward sign of
mental illness but there's grave harm
and the adjustment itself that's because
the experience
of long-term isolation can paradoxically
lead to social withdrawal at first
people are starved for human contact but
over time it becomes disorienting even
frightening they can't handle it anymore
all of this amounts to a prolonged
social death the men and ADX are stuck
in suspended animation not really part
of this world they're not really part of
any world that's fully and tangibly
human it's for all of these reasons that
international human rights law prohibits
the use of long term solitary
confinement in fact the UN is called on
governments to ban the use of solitary
for more than 15 days as of today tommy
silverstein has been in solitary for
12,800 15 days now in judging other
countries human rights records the US
State Department has called the use of
long-term solitary a human rights
violation in 2009 for example the State
Department condemned Israel Iran
Indonesia and Yemen for their use of
solitary but we allow it to happen on
our own soil when a prison is located in
the US instead of China when it's run by
the federal government not some rogue
Sheriff when it has state-of-the-art
technology and gleaming floors not
overcrowded cells and decrepit
facilities it's harder to believe that
torture happens there but it's important
to entertain the idea that sometimes
this too is what torture looks like as a
civil rights lawyer I believe it's
important to ensure that people even
those convicted of terrible crimes
aren't tortured by our government and if
this talk or a movie I'd tell you next
about how we fought and fought and
eventually won but this isn't a movie so
I'll tell you instead about how deeply
this injustice is hidden how difficult
it is to expose it and why it's
important that we do you think that
lawyers people who work in the justice
system would know what happens in our
prison
but I'm a lawyer and I live less than
two hours away from ATX and until we
went to see that first client I didn't
know anything about it I don't think
that's an accident ATX walls itself off
from public scrutiny in the 25 years
since it opened it's allowed only a
single visit by human rights
organizations journalists are routinely
denied entry mail is censored and even
when rare family visits occur they're
monitored by an unseen government
official who can cut the visit off
without notice if he thinks that the
prisoner is talking in too much detail
about the conditions and 80 acts in
China in Russia to keep out the human
rights observers keep out the media keep
out the UN and so do we
ADX is and the words of one journalist a
black site on American soil
we know that secrecy is a hallmark of
places that torture but after years of
shining a light we now know more about
the conditions in Guantanamo than we do
at ADX five years ago when there is a
hunger strike in force-feeding at
Guantanamo the same thing was happening
at ATX but you probably didn't hear
about it because the government gagged
family members and lawyers from talking
about it but here's the thing the
American criminal justice system is
supposed to be transparent and before
someone gets sent to prison that's
largely true legislators meet in public
to debate and define the laws that
prohibit criminal conduct citizens and
our communities serve as jurors on
criminal trials and if you want to watch
a trial the courtroom doors are wide
open after the trial though our
commitment to transparency ends with the
prison door securely shut what happens
behind prison walls stays behind prison
walls and without the scrutiny of the
public gaze the darkness Fester's other
than execution incarceration is the most
intrusive power of the state the
deprivation of citizens Liberty but no
government institution is
more opaque and less accountable than
prison even though prisons are supported
by taxpayers and return 95% of their
residents to our communities
it's that secrecy that allows the ADX to
disappear people and so we have an
obligation said Justice Kennedy as a
democracy and as a people we should know
what happens after the prisoner is taken
away the prison system is the concern
and responsibility of every citizen this
is your justice system these are your
prisons torture happens in the dark and
so we need to embrace the admonition
that sunlight is the best disinfectant
not only because we need to know what
happens inside ADX but because the
knowing itself can create change there's
an axiom in physics called the
uncertainty principle it teaches that
the mere fact of observation can alter
will alter the subatomic reaction being
observed in other words watching
something effects its course in a
democracy like the u.s. prisons are
administered in our name and on our
behalf the conditions in a TX implicate
our tax dollars public safety and most
of all our shared belief in the inherent
dignity of every human being we have an
obligation to bear witness thank you
[Applause]
[Music]